hello my name is Jackson i'm the founder
of the world toilet organization I like
to answer this question what is the
fundamental power that people have that
would transform the world basically we
have a wall where six and a half to
seven billion people lives on this
planet four billion up for and excluded
from our formal economy it's a very very
strange well you compete resurface the
top of the pyramid and the middle class
and the customer at the bottom of the
pyramid are actually also buying stuff
they just buying less they have less
money and since the top of the pyramid
is so saturated we should start to see
the poor as new customer the future
belongs to an inclusive society and then
where there is no poverty you have a
more stable more fairer equitable world
so let's back to think about how also to
redesign the world for the four billion
poor with durable products because
imagine is this 4 billion who gets into
the middle class and stop polluting the
same way that the two and a half billion
of us are polluting the world the world
will not be able to sustain it so since
this 4 billion base of pyramid market is
not yet sport let's take this
opportunity to design a very beautiful
not true way products a society that's
environmentally behaving correctly thank
you